[Music]
how are you greeted by cristian cásseres with
his brief news now in
spanish the metropolitan police are
investigating a fatal accident that occurred
near webmail waypoints this happened
on thursday morning the police
say a young man was speeding and
crossed a  red light and collided with
another vehicle where the driver
lost his life school authorities are
investigating the young man for
suspicious drug-related activity near
the cyber festa high school they
believe the minor was also under the
influence of toxic substances he was
hospitalized and  is critically injured
a song country flight had to make
an emergency stop at a little
before 1:30
a.m. Friday at
harry reid international airport
airport officials tell us the flight was
originally bound for many
talks  when they detected a problem
in its operation and he was
forced to land  r here in the city
no injuries reported
and to make this kind of
weird that we don't really don't see
every day a donkey was lost and was walking through
a las vegas neighborhood' the animal was
just walking around northeast of the
city  Near the high school,
a security camera managed to capture the
moment in which a couple tried to
corner him to prevent him from escaping
until the authorities arrived and we
closed the week with a
really sunny Friday, temperatures
as we can see reaching 50
degrees for the  Afternoon, they will rise later on
Saturday to a maximum of 60 degrees,
while for the next week
we will have pleasant days with the
maximum reaching 70 degrees.